Canada's prime minister, just
accused India
of assassinating somebody
on Canadian soil.
[TRUDEAU] potential link
between agents of the government of India
and the killing of a Canadian citizen.
Let me explain why this is a big deal.
Hardeep Singh
Nijjar moved to Canada from India
and was a leader
of the Khalistan movement,
an effort
to create an independent state
for Sikhs,
a religious minority in northern India.
The Indian government called this guy
a terrorist
and has been trying to arrest him
for years.
Nijjar found refuge in Canada,
where nearly a million Sikhs live.
That is,
until recently,
when he was gunned down by two men
outside of a temple in Vancouver.
India denied any involvement in this,
but Justin Trudeau's accusation
that India was involved
means that there's at least
some credible evidence here.
But we just don't know yet.
The whole thing is causing
some real tension
between the two countries.
And it's right at a time
when the West is trying
to strengthen
its relationship with India
as part of its efforts
to counterbalance China.
So I guess now we just wait
and see what evidence comes out.
If you want to better understand
global politics, follow for more.